the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok
it's a have a recap awful last lecture
so what we were doing is used the
board's my equation under relaxation
time approximation so that's a
relaxation time and under this
approximation we can write and also Nina
right so we keep the first order of the
left hand side of the board so my
equation and replace that F by F 0
that's essentially so the distortion due
to the transport and the F 0 is the
equilibrium so you for F is just equal F
0 there's no transport and per se when
we have a gradient in F 0 and in both
real space and velocity of momentum
space we have the deviation from the uke
linear right so this is the first order
solution for the board my equation under
relaxation time approximation and using
this we say from here you can look
either the heat flux the momentum flux
and they charge flux so you can do all
the flux and they gather the
considerable relations we derive the
Fourier law and in this case that we
took a fall as example F 0 is the
distribution function but in this case
the temperature become space dependent
so T is a function of X and that we do
not have the momentum dependent so we
took this out and
you get the f0f solution and from there
you calculate the heat flux and the flux
is always whatever flux we had is f
itself times the velocity in that
direction right and let's see here
and and then you sum up of all these
states and per unit area so Luminizer
per volume right so this is the flux
itself and of course if you want to
calculate momentum you put a momentum
Pro quantum state so if you calculate
the heat that's a heat carried energy
carry per quantum state and Lex the
water we plan to do is to calculate that
they charge flocks the current so we're
doing electrons and just see where of
the common if we're also for for long
it's T is a function of X and then when
we did the Newland shear stress law we
see f0 is we replace whether they
displaced
Boersma this Maxwell distribution right
because the molecule has a long zero
average velocity U this is the average
velocity way is the phase space velocity
the way self care from a scene from to
plus infinite but the U is a function of
the space owning that's the average over
all the momentum space right so this
case U is a function of R so that's
where we took a derivative we again look
at the momentum flux we got the noodle
insurance Fresnel and I might just a
comment for example if you want look at
this if it is the function of X you have
both momentum transport and also say the
spatial dependent due to temperature
right temperature could also drive the
mass flow
and this is in fact that copper the heat
and mass transfer and we don't we didn't
go into those details and if you want to
derive I think at one of the homework
it's actually doing the summer can
derive thermal conductivity for guest
molecules and in that case you actually
have to do say see a mass balance and
heat balance and this way you will say
the more clearly in the example were
drilling and that's actually for the
copper the charge and the heat transfer
when we do with electrons so at the end
of last lecture we discussed the
electron transport and we finally show
that the solution will apply to electron
is the F zero and then this grid in
terms the complication for electrons
that will not only have spatial gradient
due to the Fermi Dirac distribution here
but also we have the force applied to
electron and because we will have an
electrostatic field the field or actor a
force right under electrostatic field so
we combine all those and we derive at
the end we have three terms DF DX EF is
the chemical potential and DC DX which
is the electrostatic potential this is a
year outcome coming the word of
reference and DT DX where I have
temperature gradient okay so I have
those three terms and the d FD k èk is
the kinetic energy
so this is a where we spend it I made
some comments so you have to understand
that what's the chemical potential
what's the electrostatic potential and
what's the electrochemical potential
right so we said the difference between
ESA and the Fermi level right is the
electrochemical potential so is here is
info this mule is relative to whatever
absolutely the reference of flat
reference and this meal is made of the
electrochemical potential which
determine how many particles I have so
how many particle I have in the
conduction band if you look at this is
the EK so this is the kinetic energy
relative to the bottom of the conduction
band
that's ek minus EE F so this year full
relative EC is legged here so that's the
difference there you came a year right
so this is self determine the Lambor of
particles in the conduction band so
that's consistent with the chemical
potential determine is related to number
of particles right
and si relative to the absolute level is
where the potential energy of the
electron the bottom of the electron
that's where the potential energy is so
mule which is a combination of EF + you
say relative to absolute is the
electrochemical potential is combined
the congregate injure with the electric
potential so when I look at the driving
force in fact you can say EF and the 2
gradient electrostatic potential
gradient and camera pro potential
gradient are equivalent positions they
can both drive the charge flow and then
we have a temperature gradient so with
this you can move the two the rest for
example I want to calculate
the charge flocks I'm doing kill right
for electron Q is negative yi for holes
Q is positive so I'm just going to use
kill and if I want to look at that the X
direction so I have way X I have Q and I
have an F I have say two factor of two
to counter for the spin and I come out K
X K Y KZ right so you can say if I
replace Q by mass per charge
I guess the mass flux it doesn't matter
when I deal with the electron flow by
the American when I deal with the mass
diffusion right
so all those is under the same idea
it really difference is one so the
quantity were interested and once they
are detail of the F itself and starting
from here your tax is the same as we did
for the Fourier law pollutant shear
stress law you're going to convert this
summation into integration you choose
your own coordinate whether you want to
work with the energy you won't work with
the momentum if you recall for Fourier
law will work with the frequency for
newton shear stress law we actually
worked with V X V Y V Z and here you can
the best day you still work with the
energy e K in this case because the F
itself depends on F 0 if there has a
inside and that would be the easiest way
to to deal with so I'm not going to go
through the intermediate step and I'm
going to give you the final result what
I have is a capital L 1 1 minus 1 over
here d EF the X plus D say
DX plus l1 to minus DT DX so the current
flow is copper to electrochemical
potential gradient and temperature
gradient ef+ you see again is D meal so
here is the mu DX minus the kill and
sometimes is also written as they kill
meal over Q let's use the capital Phi DX
and see this is called the EMF
electro-motive force okay it's
combination alpha electrostatic and
chemical potential grid I say for C so
here because the C remember this are the
energy units when I talk about your
actress static potential yeah I do
actually
EC divided by Q normalized by charge so
there are different units and even they
all called potential 7 is the energy
unit and the other is energy divided by
Coulomb right so I have this Kofi the
copper transport you know 1 1 a 1 2 let
me give you the expression for L 1 1 l 1
2 and the L 1 1 after you do all your
math integration you say it's the 1/3
q square 0 to infinite and the way
square tau and the D UK and DF 0 the UK
and Bek and if I do have a probiotic
band remember the energy ek is 1/2 MV
square over 2 right
or if I do they say in quantum term is
say 2m H bar square K because M way is
the momentum H Bar K so you can convert
this way into ek and do your integration
okay so this is the one coefficient and
the other coefficient L 1/2 is my skew
divided by 3 T 0 to infinite way square
tau and the e K must EF TF 0 the UK de K
so if I now they tense up States oh I
should have been subspace density of
states the UK okay so if you know the
density of states you know the oxygen
time you can calculate those transport
coefficient right and if you recall when
we talked about the electron energy
levels according a panty model those are
the different ways to calculate the
details of the band structure of
different materials from that you can
get this up States and from density
start states you dope the material so
based on doping you can determine where
is your year yeah if can be adjusted by
doping okay and this is a harder to
calculate how relaxation time we
discussed in fact I say they are really
not good way not many calculation of the
relaxation time for electrons and
because they say once you go to there's
a scattering process it's always a
higher order and more difficult with
your ways but say in general the
framework
is there like a you do density function
theory you can calculate the band
structure of different materials and
calculate then sub states a year for
this other quantity and from there you
can potentially also calculate the
scattering rate using the perturbation
method like Fermi golden rule okay so
those are the generic of a function or
form we have and let's look a little
more into details what the solution
tells us okay so first let's look at a
constant temperature case there's no
temperature gradient and in the case of
constant temperature let's drop the
first term the second term here right
then the current of flux is related to
electrochemical potential gradient I
further or distinguish it say metal and
then in metal the electron density is
very high so effectively there's no
change in the electron density and if
you recall the difference say between
metal a semiconductor when we discuss
before this is the electron energy
momentum let's say here is the say
electron band structure the energy we
vector relation in case of metal my
Fermi level is a deep into the band
right this is my EF and the most of this
charge below the Fermi level war they
don't have because they are mala mobile
the the affair of the stage so only
about the KT near the Fermi level
the charge that actually moves right so
in this case if I look either the the
term EF which is a camber pottinger the
charge number density of the charge e in
the middle doesn't change much so DF DX
can be dropped out it's really
electrostatic potential pretty much that
is driving the charge flow and if I look
at the transport essentially this is
Ohm's law
right Jake hill the current flux is
proportional to the electron can group
the potential gradient and the put l11
is the electric conductivity so I have
l1 y is the electric conductivity and in
the case of metal right this
differentiation is nonzero near the
Fermi level and then other places they
are all pretty much zero so I can
approximate this indigo with one sir
how F this is the relaxation time at the
Fermi level and density of states at the
Fermi level e square VF velocity at the
Fermi level so this is the electric
conductivity and which you can further
read in because you say you can relate
density of states to the electron
lambert density in the material so this
is any square cm tau F okay so that's
the electric conductivity in methyl is
many the carrier density doesn't change
much is the electrostatic potential
that's driving the current flow now if
we look at a semiconductor
and in semiconductor I have both the
carrier density and the electrochemical
put the electrostatic potential gradient
they all could vary in the semiconductor
if when you make a PN Junction for
example there is a large change in the
band edge of the semiconductor so
post-term is changing and the current
density is often reading ice rather than
writing into just this term you actually
sometimes split this out one is really a
density FDX
that's real little carrier density this
one is related to electrostatic
potential so the a semiconductor the
famous equation people show up is a Q
and mule insulin X that's the electric
field okay which is the gradient of
ligand you just say 1 or kill decd X
okay and plus a diffusion term DN DX
because de f ef determined the carrier
density there is a fixed relation
between y EF and n so DF DX is DN DX and
with the diffusion coefficient a so here
is diffusivity
and here is the reason it's written in
metal we don't talk about the mule we
talk about Sigma in semiconductor this
end changes a lot
so you luminize the Sigma this Q and
milk gives you Sigma electric
conductivity right so here is Sigma and
this mule is the mobility okay
so Sigma equals Q mu and if you go back
to here because Sigma is ne square M PI
F right so in general milk is related to
M and tau so no no and eat how say e toh
see the yeah / M right so measuring the
mobility effectively you say in this
you have the effective mass you have the
relaxation time so it's a measure of the
relaxation time and all give you
information about the effective mass
okay and now you can say in fact both of
those terms right have the same
coefficient I'm just writing splitting
them up so this is a diffusivity and the
mobility are related to each other and
the relation between diffusivity and the
mobility a is a KB T over Yi times mu
and this is a called Einstein relation
okay it's a general relationship I say
between the mobility and diffusivity
Einstein didn't work on this okay what
he really worked on is the Brownian
motion and in the case of Brownian
motion the particle diffusivity and
think about the milk molecules in water
right the milk molecule diffusivity is
related to viscosity of the fluid so
this is a general in fact I say they're
generalization of this as I said before
Einstein started this other direction
linear response theory and this is a
part of C dissipation fluctuation
dissipation theorem general very general
say this is a diffusion is a fluctuation
process mobility is a dissipation
collision process so that's a
fluctuation dissipation theorem that's a
why example of fluctuation dissipation
theorem Einstein relation between the
mass diffusion and viscosity this is
another example so there are many
example of fluctuation dissipation very
general so what the electrical engineer
do is solving this equation here is
called drift diffusion so this is the
drift diffusion equation okay so if you
look at a lot of things in fact you and
nowadays write this CMOS si si si mas
right you all know it's a metal oxide
theory effect transistors right and you
always the gate now shrink that who
tends I don't know exactly how many
20 or 30 nanometers the industry is
still using this equation okay
and we just tweak the parameters they
tweak the mobility parameter diffusivity
parameters just to fade the device
characteristics and the null is not call
valid because the electron mean free
path could be larger but it's building
many software it's amazing that they can
still use it to design the circuits okay
so that's the semiconductor diffusion
equation if you design solar cell this
will be the equation in this wall most
of solar cells okay and so now let's
look at that the first case we discussed
as a constant temperature and let's
discuss it when temperature is not
constant right
and it's a function of X so in this case
I have a material I have a temperature
gradient right and in the extra ration
heat conduction and what happened say
first day if I open circuit
je equals zero so what do you have if
you have open circle J or not EQ I know
Y is a 4 electron Curie the more general
sometimes I switch because there are not
enough symbols okay when you deal with
the heated like to use a kill and we
deal with the charge you like to use the
e by the years negative all this
complication but open circuit right if
you look at my flux equation here and
what I have is this is zero
but I have two terms on the right-hand
side dtdx is now zero so I will have D
Phi DX non zero that balance it so what
I really have in this case I have my
Seebeck coefficient is defined as the
negative D Phi DX this is a essentially
they sometimes we usually say electric
field the epsilon X right let's say I
use the internal X before so I'm just
going to defy the X and DT DX okay and
this one is the Seebeck coefficient and
the equals L 1 2 0 1 1 and remember your
minus Sigma so if I look at this I
substitute the expression for those
coefficients right if you say the
difference of the tool waist square tau
which were talk D D D F 0 DK the
difference is just UK mass here and of
course in the front there's more
difference right so what I have here is
I will have e over tau ET his
temperature is the positive charge no
sign problem way square tau and the EK e
masse F the F 0 DK and density of states
UK UK I write it because I want to
explain what it means right way square
tau the F 0 DK DK so you can say that
this is the Seebeck effect
Seebeck coefficient and Seebeck effect
was discovered in 1821 that was about
same time electricity was studied and so
basically when you apply a temperature
gradient to material you generate
electrochemical potential gradient okay
and what happens now if you look at this
is a temperature gradient drive a
diffusion right current so when I have
higher temperature the electrons diffuse
faster they come to this side they're
more on this side when they're more the
chemical potential will change the
electrostatic potential which and they
readjusted to resist the diffusion so
this term is resist diffusion this is
diffusion right driving force so at the
end you have a lad open circuit let's
charge equal zero right
next card conflict core 0 and you have
voltage developed across the material
okay and so that's the phenomenological
explanation now if I connect this to the
band structure so here is my conduction
band I just look at the conduction band
right here is a word the chemical
potential level formula voice and ek my
CF so is this difference right I said
this is you say this is the EF itself
right ek is here so I have became a CF
so it's the average energy you can say
here this is the you can my CF is that
so the rest is just so they here you can
think about that each
electron I certainly know g-level has a
specific energy dependent spectral
contribution to electric conductivity
and I'm averaging that to the
differential electric conductivity there
right so Seebeck coefficients is the
average of the electron energy relative
to the tango potential okay
and this also the electron energy right
- chemical potential is the heat so is
the average energy per charge and you
use thermocouple so next time you can
say you imagine a voltage rating out of
the thermocouple fundamentally is the
average is actually the heat per charge
carried your better and he charge
carries also the entropy per charge
carried so the Seebeck coefficient is
really entropy of the charge okay and
with that that you can also appreciate
why metal has a low Seebeck coefficient
so if I look how to say metal I draw the
Fermi level of metal here right and is
the if the electron is above the Fermi
level they have positive heat if you
lack trauma below the Fermi level they
have lady heat but in metal you're
averaging over all positive negative
they cancel each other right so that's
why metal has a low Seebeck coefficient
and in a semiconductor my hole is here
my EF is very close to the chemical
potential to the conduction band or very
close to the valence band so Longley I
won the one type of carrier and do they
do not cancer
other but in fact that she the most
certainly actually the fact that you
actually that don't weigh the very
heavily into the band okay so your
chemical but then getting into the very
close to the bottom conducting but
another but above it and in that case
those carriers in the bottom below that
chemical potential is actually harmful
they do cancel right so that's why in
some of those structure people want
rather than this kind of parabolic
attend sub States but if you have those
kinds of densities out States shaft
features you will be better okay that's
what a quantum size effects and or we
can go or discuss more side effects in
the next chapter so this is the Seebeck
effect and that's they so associated
with the charge flow I have also the
heat carried by that due to the drive
the charge flow and now let's look at ER
the utter which is the heat carried
right heat flow okay and what is the
heat flow I already mentioned that the
EEMA he came a CF is the heat carry and
in fact you can write down the energy
equals write the first law tells us that
the energy equals to the heat plus EF DN
right the chemical potential times today
change in the number of particles that's
a first law you can also add the
electrostatic so basically the energy in
the material is say n times the energy
per charge right that's my E or here
so you can say d kill per charge is a
massy yet so it's really the heat is
here ek minus EF is my heat so this heat
carried the per se quantum state so with
that I can go to calculate what's the
total amount of heat when the Condor
also flows in the material so J kill I
think my book I used the wind je the
other is Jake smoke kill button since
I've been keeping Jay kill as for the
charge so now I'm doing the chapter kill
okay so jko then is tool over way K X K
Y KZ right and if you look at here when
we do the charge for quantum state is
kill right and here what I have is the
heat is the UK masse EF and we X F so
again I'm applying my general expression
general with how to find that what's the
flux for different quantities and you go
through the conversion of the summation
into integration again and what you find
out is I have L to 1 minus D Phi again D
Phi DX because I already have F right
and plus l22 months DT DX so this is the
Carnot flux so I have a set of coupled
expression J for the electric car is L 1
1 D Phi DX and there 1 2 DT DX and for
the heat flow I have 2 1 l 2 2
TDX right and in fact that there is a
very fundamental relation between those
coefficients anytime you see couple to
couple the expressions or I say the
charge is coupled to temperature that's
a cross term right
if you write a cross term into a general
entropy so this is a generalized
thermodynamics the general thermodynamic
the driving force for the flux the heat
flux and any other flux charge flux is
the entropic gradient there okay and for
entropy if you recall is D D X 1 over T
and the kill right so that's the so it's
T in the denominator so so any of this
if you write into generalized entropy as
a driving force then these cross
coefficients are always equal and this
is the fundamental say answer
correlation so here we have an sagar
relation and in this case because I'm
not writing say L to 1 say a DT DX in
terms of entropy if I use the entropy
say they should echo up either because
I'm not using the entropy so I have T l2
y equals T times 0 1 2 ok so any time
this is like I said any cup of the
process you can always ask where is your
answer correlation next time you go to
seminar right a guy talk about piezo
electric piezo electric is the
electrical and the pressure that gotta
be that coupling coefficient from
electrical to pressure to force all from
force to electrical their coefficients
always obey the answer correlation okay
and so that's the form and I'm not even
going to write down this expression in
soil in the book and again let's look
either the the implication right and if
I first look at a constant I say
temperature case again I flow currents
through the material right and this term
drops out this term drops out but I can
replace D Phi DX by Jake hill right then
I have a relation between the Heat
current and the electric current so if
you do that relation if I say you'll
have here you have the heat current will
be related to the electric current l 2 1
l 1 1 + je jake hill right so this is
the pouty effect so when you fly flow a
current through a conductor associated
with current there's a heat carry by the
charge and this is reversible when you
change the current direction so this is
the Peltier coefficient coefficient
and this is the power of the effects
itself is the fact that cells that
actually don't manifest just seeing a
semi inseam mature and what happens is
that when you put a to mature together
one amateur tool and it has a current
now at the junction you do your energy
balance because because the Peltier
coefficient difference so there's more
heat flow out or more heat flow in at
the junction because of this difference
so you have cooling or heating depends
on the current direction which is
reversible as you change your current
direction okay and of course if you look
at this because our Seebeck effect that
is L 1 to L 1 1 and L 2 is the tl12 so I
know this pi the Peltier coefficient is
actually related to C back just a times
absolute temperature so this tool are
related to each other and this was a say
this is a quarter Kelvin relation but
it's the one special example of the
general unsecured relation I just said
right Kelvin's much earlier the answer
go
I'm sorry go Lori price also for the
unskilled relation he developed ok and
so we have the example of the the Kelvin
relation is an example of the answer and
I think I mentioned this before Calvin
is say is the Lord Kelvin and there is a
same as a Thompson ok I say if you check
I wrote over 500 papers during its
lifetime in the eighteen eighteen
hundreds it's not easy you want to type
it
okay so that's the one case and second
case if I just combine this two equation
I can always eliminate the electro
chemical potential D Phi DX D Phi DX in
term Express kill heat flux in terms of
current flux so what I have if I
eliminate the D Phi DX what I have in
general
Jake hill equals PI J kill so that's the
pout here and then I have a little X
term is l1 1 l1 - l2 - minus l1 to l2 1
divided by L 1 1 and times DT DX here in
front DT DX so what it what it means
normally you would probably tend to
think L 2 2 is your thermal conductivity
right that's not the case because you
can say when I flow current is through
the material the heat flow is one-termer
is the Peltier heat flow and second term
is a temperature gradient driven and so
if this temperature gradient driven is
not just l2 - is this all combined
together and so here this term is the ke
is electronic because here I'm modern
electrons right I mean the photons have
already did before falling with either
the thermal conductivity expression
electronic thermal conductivity is the
ke is this blob there it's a combination
of the three coefficients okay
and so you feel a medal and you can show
that I say okay ke again say all this
roughly give you a waxer to say we
square tau and how is the energy
relaxation time and you can look at all
those and actually find the relation
because you will surely what's
collecting there if you look at their
solution F has a towel right F itself as
tau has a way at sea at the end you have
digital states so the difference between
those different coefficients just the
weather is the averaging the charge is
averaging the energy so because of that
this ke and the thermal conductivity and
the electrical conductivity actually
related if you recall in the last
lecture we mentioned for the gas it's
the same right the viscosity and thermal
conductivity are related so all this is
because you come from the pretty much of
the same equation except that I'm doing
different averaging so what I have in
this is ke Sigma T and in particularly
metal this one is a constant and this is
a PI square over a third and kb / e
square and there is a 2.45 10 to the
mass 8 all what kelvins square and this
is Lauren's lumber and Norns
and this is a court this called a
windmill friends law so in metal the
electrical conductivity divided by
electronic contribution due to thermal
conductivity divided by electric
conductivity the Romagna is temperature
because specific heat of electron is a
linear proportion of the temperature and
that ratio gives you constant and if you
check a lot of material metal in meadow
the dominant heat career is electrons
and fallen contributor probably less
than 10 percent in general and you will
see that indeed the electrical and this
is very close to this ratio okay so a
simple lazy way if you don't know the
electric and thermal conductivity which
is harder to measure the measure
electrical activity you can give you an
estimation right and of course to say if
you do semiconductor that's a little bit
different and the Simek if you do
semiconductor you have to go back to all
this expression and turns out that this
Norns number depends on karat
concentration okay because your EF is
changing right different doping will
change the Fermi level and his say all
those coefficient depends on Fermi level
so but they rent you so far this range
so far has not changed much and the
cirrie i've seen is a property of fact
within fact of to difference but say
it's a fine chelation but it's the
radical possibility that i have is how
one can design a material so that they
electronica thermicon idea is zero right
but the electric on that here is now
zero
and in Sidi if you if you go to check
when this is zero and but you don't want
the l110 you actually say functionally
is possible okay
so this is how you actually achieve this
in real materials because that's very
important when you deal with
thermoelectrics okay so we have started
from the distribution function the
deviation and we say okay if you write
all those coefficients you should be
able to show the fundamental this is a
say they coupled charge to electrical
and temperature gradient and the heat
carried by the charge to the
electrochemical gradient and temperature
gradient right this is are the unsecured
type of relations and in many many say
in fact that those are there are many
very interesting cop of the process and
I mention a piezoelectric recently say
they are also I'm getting interested in
this so called a spin so electron spin
can also carry heat and the spin see
back there
this becomes a called hot topic if
you're interested in can check
literature and magnetic si si
we talked about electron we talked a
phonon and there are also the so called
Meg longs the magnetic c collecting
motion of the waves of the magnetic
field so all those say effects could be
coupled and this is this coupling that
probably can lead some very interesting
technology or effects and so it's a it's
the worst-looking and if you do he that
mass transfer again those are couple
right and then in the heat and mass
transfer there is also fundamental
relation between the heat transfer
coefficient that the coupling
coefficient that's again example
manifestation of the general unsecured
relation
okay so I want to deepen and getting
into more detail thermoelectric I look
at my Oh progress so far I found out
what lecture behind so what I'm doing is
trying to combine this into the
thermoelectric slasher I have 30 minutes
okay you already have this
thermoelectric effect so it should be
not too difficult and what I want to say
tell you is a word is it he come from
ZT right so given what do you have
learned I can write the energy balance
and if I you can start with the
differential because the equation I have
given you differential equations so if I
think about the in general when I have a
conductor right I take a differential
element I have both heat and the charge
flow in the material this is a X X plus
DX right here I have the jakeel at the X
and here I have a GQ at the X plus DX
right and when I look at the energy
balance under a electrical field I also
have the change in electro chemical
potential right so if I write my energy
balance for this problem so I have Jake
hill I the X - Jake hill at the X plus
DX that's the heat carried by charge
flowing
- flow out and I could have also of
you can think about that you can have
converging or that radiation I'm
neglecting that but because I have
you'll actually field I can not look
like that so my field is the current how
much energy does charge are losing is
how much electrochemical potential
gradient that had lost in this section
right so this ID defy gives me zero so
that's my energy balance and if I
sometimes I also feel this is not
necessary I can just write them I hear
is my heat equation right he cared about
charge but if I add a electrochemical
energy by charge together that's a total
energy energy flux and that will give me
same expressions so this is a
electrochemical heat and if you now
substitute what we have here right
eventually I wrote down a different
expression here oops
erasing okay so the the question we are
just written down so if this is a
cross-section a so what I'll have is
after I put it in is DT a times D DX
this is the heat term the difference of
this tool gives me the power TL hands
the car electric current master daylight
warning thermal conductivity DT DX and
in fact I say I should erase this
electronic I should just use the total
thermal because I also have photons
right I have the lattice heat conduction
so I combined them all together DT DX
and then DX so this is a day in the
difference of the tool over the section
DX plus I D Phi DX D Phi equals zero I
recall that I have to when I look at the
D Phi DX I have to look at the Jake Hill
and DT DX term right it's coupled right
what I'm gonna have a D Phi DX I have to
go back and replace D Phi DX in terms of
Jake hill and DT DX I have another term
right so now you putting all this
together I'm not going through the math
and the what do you have is a K if i
zoom time to your deeper I see some
we're gonna do is a temperature
independent that's the first term DT DX
K DT DX square that's a typical without
having a heat conduction equation but a
highway extra term that's what I want to
show this is a je Jake Hill T D s DT and
DT DX
plus J Square over Sigma equals zero so
this is the jaw hidden right it's a I
square R this is the heat conduction
normal heat conduction this term is
reversible there's an extra term when I
pass a current through a same material
and depends out the rashing of this car
at the relative temperature gradient I
can have all along the material heating
and cooling okay and this is a Thomson
term I'm saying effect so that's a law
Kelvin and he discovered so sit back and
powder were all experimental to discover
and he tried to connect them and he said
there has to be a third effect and he
was the owner for this Thompson in fact
and this one is reversible when you pass
current and see through the material and
in fact I say the negative sign because
we have here is more heat generation
this is a cooling in the current say
location there so the Thompson effect
for this times in fact that we can also
define Thomson coefficient so
thermoelectric in fact when we talk
about After Effects there are actually
three effects so it comes and
coefficient is they cool in the local
cooling / GJ e Jake Hill DT DX and this
one is T vs DT and this is a Thomson
coefficient so in fact say also my
electric coefficient Thomson coefficient
here terrible relation between pouty and
Seebeck coefficient you see it's all
related right
and there was a very interesting guy in
thermal electrics and it's a Russian and
he has a book on some way that very
likely effects it's depending on how
you're a range of magnetic field
temperature gradient current flow there
probably over 100 effects he has a
toilet table here okay every time I go
to thermoelectric conference we give a
talk you'll see that table some of this
might be interesting I really haven't
looked into all those details but so the
point is to see those couple transport
there are many variations and so now you
can go ahead go to Saab this is a
differential equation right if you
typically your seatback go fishing will
be indeed temperature dependent so
you're going to go to solve it and the
most time this coefficient that comes in
fact is actually is not very strong so
it's you can approximate it neglecting
so if you look like that now we go to
look at a simple device analysis
right so the simple of this device is
just a one leg normally you do you'll
ever use one leg because you have to put
the leads there but when you think about
analysis let's say if I do a cooling
right if I pass a car in this room and
see the current let's say this is a hos
positive charge so the current flow in
this direction the whole float is the
ration the carry energy from this side
to the other side this side cools down
this I heats up right so let's say this
is a heart this is a code that could you
could create a Peltier cooler that's the
current application in thermal electrics
mostly is using you for cooling and so
if I lick left they Thompson in fact you
go to solve this equation based on the
boundary condition th here you can find
the temperature gradient temperature
profile in the material that's a easy
right uniform heat generation
heat conduction it took a hit if you
took a heat transfer core so you can
solve it but if not but you can still
solve this it's a second order very easy
differentiation okay so if you solve it
you will find out the heat conduction at
the cold surface right you have
conduction and this conduction is
because you established by cooling you
stopped your time to Agreda and th and
TC so you have a reverse heat flow due
to heat conduction of the material so
this key conduction is a K a th mass TC
and this is coming back this is actually
not what do you want right and people
also there's another term because I have
a jar of heating term so this jar
heating again you can prove exactly
mathematically right your reading is a
uniform distributed lag if you solve
that equation you find out one half go
back right the other half goes to the
other direction so what you have is a
1/2 I square I is the card
R is the electric resistance so you're
actually resistance is the 1 over Sigma
L over a right it always the length a is
the cross section so this is a
conduction do - they stop the tumbler
difference the reverse flow and deal to
the jar heat conduct back at this
interface so this is reverse heat flow
back and now if you make a cooler your
electrical current is flow this duration
they carry a heat away from this
interface so the lad cooling he'll
cooling is the Peltier coefficient times
current which apologia is TS Thompson
times current and then counter balanced
by this reverse heat flow which is it so
let's say our say kth okay this is a
conductance right K th th must EC minus
1/2 I square re
so this is the left cooling you have
what do you really want is this char but
because of the mature has a spineless
thermal conductivity you want a zero
that's good right so you have heat
reverse back you have jar heating in the
material so you also don't like that you
want the s is large so and but you look
at this the coolant powder coating is a
linear proportional to current jar
headings I square so
there's an optimum current you can take
that you'll find that I optimum then you
take the gradient equals zero derivative
equals 0 then the I optimum is st say
over re so that's the optimum current
for the cooling and in this case you'll
have the maximum cooling okay
the maximum cooling I'm not going to
write it down but when the maximum
cooling is zero you see why you do you
do that
when zero actually create the largest
delta T you don't cool anything your
maximum of the other t you can have
right so the maximum delta T I'm going
to write it down so when you have also
kill cool pulling equals zero then you
gather your maximum t-pod non-sticky
called maximum and it turns out is a
quadratic equation is 1/2 z GC Square
and this is a is famous as a key figure
of Merit of the material where they
including s square Sigma over K and this
is the figure of America
okay so the unit of this is the universe
Kelvin you go to check and the Mosel
Tommy appears as the product of Z with
the temperature so ZT is a
non-dimensional oh okay this is a Kuni
but say for cooling I don't necessarily
want I want them what's the most
efficient right I also care about the
efficiency of cooling you know make a
refrigerator and that's a C so you don't
coefficient that when you make a
refrigerator you say what do you pay
electricity and what are you getting and
cooling that's coefficient of
performance so COP of cooling is Q of
cooling and how much you pay in your
electrical bill the power right and the
cooling already have so what I have here
this one you can say is a function
powerful but let me just call I'm not
going to copy it but you can you can put
this one there but what's interesting is
that what in this case so what's the
electrical power you have to put in
right no more you would say I square R
but that's not the case for
thermoelectrics you will have I square R
ye okay
that's the resistant internal resistance
but you also produce here a seatback
voltage in the s th month t say right so
if you think about that i'm drawing in
the positive feedback so the Seebeck
voltage is actually reversed because you
have more acid away okay so you have
more choice
arch in this direction then this
direction so you you have so you have
the what I want to see is that what
should be this and sometimes I'm getting
confused now so the sign should be
because I'm only using one type material
but if it's a it's basically I need to
put in more power the generator Seebeck
voltage resists my current flow so is
the s th mass t say times the I so this
is additional voltage generate due to
the current due to the temperature
difference exist across the device okay
so I'm paying more to overcome that
temperature difference so because of
this you can say when I'm opting myself
here I have taken the derivative of this
with respect to a current that's
different than I take a derivative of Q
with respect to card I have a different
optimum point for maximum efficiency
versus maximum cooling power those are
the operation of the device okay so you
optimize this what do you find out you
if you maximize so this is like when you
operate your solar cell right there is
always optimum point because you don't
want to run say see a solar cell later
on you'll learn this is the solar cell
typically Karam voltage and you want to
say this is a your current this is a
voltage this is a current and you want
to optimize so that the current times
the voltage is maximum okay so the those
kind of solid state device there's
always optimal loading you match the
external load to the internal node and
then when I do that my optimum se Co P
is T say TS minus T say this is a carlo
factor
if you have Carlo engine that's what you
get and then one plus is ATM Massa th
over T se and square root 1 plus is ATM
- 100 plus 1 ok so this is a long idea
factor here z TM TM is the average of th
monster TC so you can say I always get a
product of Z times T that's where the ZT
come from ok here is the color factor
here is a long idea mature factor and
you want to improve this mature ZT so
you increase those right and you will
say this is a probably about the 115
many given Z T equals 1 that's another
material car material and that factor
Nong idea factor is 1/5 so it depends of
course that depends on how large is your
th much do you say just can't reach
certain if you teach your TC is too
large it's likely you don't make a
refrigerator all of it you have maximum
the other t that you can achieve okay
and you can also make a power generator
you reverse it you make a power
generator and that's they again if you
make a power generator you have a
maximally say efficiency and then you
need to know match it so in the case of
power generator
you're maximally efficient say if you do
it is this is again Carlo factor if you
operate the heat engine between the TC
and th and the imperfection due to
material is a 1 z TM minus 1 1 plus is a
TM plus TC over th so this is a
everything widely in the thermoelectric
people will say what's your ZT because
you can't do much with the color factor
of course you can always depend on heat
source temperature range you can improve
this one higher temperature but it's the
mature also how much you can reach
compared to car oh okay and feel more
comments first we if we do a summary of
actual material even if you get your
best thermoelectric material at the hand
you may not know it because right
thermoelectric material is a three
parameter and this three parameter ZT
right if we look at Z T electron in the
denominator thermal conductivity is the
electronic thermal conductivity plus
full-on thermal conductivity you have
both right k is k e+ k fo lon okay so we
said that in thermoelectric so this
Fermi level can be controlled by doping
right so it turns out the electric
conductivity
Seebeck coefficient all depends on
doping and if you dope it say very high
you get into metal see back cancel each
other we comment before right see back
in mother's very low so see
drop as you increase your carrier
concentration on the harder had the
electric conductivity if you look at is
the mobility times carrier concentration
times charge so you'll actually
conductivity will increase write Sigma
yes so you have to optimize s square
Sigma I need to knock to my right and in
fact that you and this maximum point may
not be the maximum because your ke
depends on carrier concentration okay so
your ke ke is normally small but this is
a K typical for long which is the
quadrant dependable care concentration
Tara can scatter funa once you get a lot
very high carrier concentration with my
friends law will say it's proportional
Sigma K right so that gives you a
typical ZT curve this is your Zeta and
this is a in material it's about 10 to
the 19 could be a 10 to the 17 to 10 to
21 this is the wrench
so that's what I say this is a 1 over
centimeter cubic so even if you have the
best material may not know it because
your dopinder is not right you see this
one doesn't work so that's the
difficulty with certain latter you have
to control you have to search you have
you change you one parameter the other
parameter change I mean sometimes with
people this is a contra properties right
say one way the other way they so how
you can be how you can fool the material
or you can fool later to get a better
materials second comment is this is a TZ
is a same so like or an ass's
temperature independent but it's never
time very independent it's always a
temperature dependent so you go to look
at their temperature dependence alright
this is temperature and sit back
typically increase with temperature
why is that so when I look at a similar
a semiconductor I increase the
temperature the Fermi level moved
through the center of the band so y EF
who actually goes to Center I'm changing
the average energy of EF and electron so
that energy difference becomes larger
okay but they only increase with a
certain level things start to drop why
is that that's because when I go to very
high temperature this is at the center
there are equal number of electron holes
the hole carry negative charge they
cancel the positive charge so you and
though the current contribute to the
electric conductivity both because you
have electron hole the energy that
carries the opposite and the cancer each
other so this is a bipolar and the
bipolar is really bad okay so what
happens the electric car is typically
drop and this they may not gather at the
same point same temperature but those
are different signs of bipolar and also
interesting is the is bad it's because
the thermo is also shooting up at the
bipolar that's because when bipolar
hurry the electron hole diffuse from one
side to the other the actual carry the
band gap energy so they carry a lot of
heat so thermal current here is large
which also this eighty will peak a
certain temperature this is eighty or
pick a certain temperature so for
different application you need optimize
and find the material for different
temperature range so those are the
challenges you do thermoelectrics okay
I'll stop here